hey youtubers it's Charlie so Batman
Arkham night is coming out this month so
I wanted to do a video for like my
favorite different Batman comics you
know just based on different artists
over the years throughout the decades
Batman has changed quite a bit you know
from like the Bob Kane era through Jim
Lee and now like present-day typically
when new artists are brought on or new
writers there's a big shift in the tone
of the character right now
DC is getting ready to do that again the
version we meet in Arkham Knight is all
action based I mean you know just lends
itself to video games comic books you
know a lot more complex a little more
story based I do think eventually though
like comic books and video games will
merge into like a singular format
they'll be you know comic books will
just become much more interactive let's
all just hold our breaths for
choose-your-own-adventure virtual
reality Batman stories so going all the
way back to the beginning gave me we got
to start with Bob Kane most of the early
Batman stories took cues from the shadow
Doc Savage soro
Dick Tracy the Phantom all of the really
famous pulp characters the early artists
for this period were Dick Spring and
Jerry Robinson up and to the point they
introduced Robin to the comics you know
you saw a lot of monsters a lot of
really dark gangster stories once Robin
came along though it had turned into
lighter fantasy a really fun story to
check out from this era is Batman number
one like the official first one the
Joker Returns
remember Batman originally debuted in
Detective Comics not in his own title if
you want another deep cut check out
Detective Comics number 38 that that's
the Robin the Boy Wonder
that was just the era went you know most
of the Batman characters that you know
about today most of the biggest
characters all debuted oh you know under
the watchful eye of Bob Kane there's a
lot of theories that he technically did
not create the Batman character - or
even the Joker I mean it is a big
controversy his writer at the time Bill
Finger asserted that he was the one that
came up with the idea for the Joker
based on this Coney Island ride and that
he also influenced the look of the
original Batman character last year
whenever they had like the Batman 75th
anniversary there's a whole bunch of
interviews about you know like the
suppose a true origin of the Batman
character moving into the 1950s Batman
shifted into more you know sci-fi
territory just because people felt like
like the crime drama was displayed in
such a light way that people were
starting to emulate it like little kids
were starting to mimic the Joker
so just decided step crazy
lawsuits you know he started moving into
more sci-fi territory and people also
started to complain that the character
was promoting homosexuality so they
introduced Batgirl that was kind of the
beginning of the bad family - but I just
think it's funny that that was a
reaction to people saying that Batman
promoted homosexuality some deep cuts to
check out from this era our Detective
Comics number 233 that's the bat woman
obviously the you know the arrival of
Batgirl and a good example of like a
real a sci-fi Batman story is Batman the
Superman of Planet X that's Batman
number 113 like I said 1950s science
fiction stories moving into the 1960s
Batman comics has started to sell really
poorly like his tends to happen from
decade to decade you know just they hit
like a big wall so they got way way
darker this is in stark contrast to the
tone of the TV show the original Adam
West TV show that debuted in 1966 so as
much as people complained that the TV
shows don't reflect the comic books
right now the same was true back in the
1960s like here in Batman number 156 he
hallucinates Robin's death on an
alternate planet would not be the last
time that he had to watch a Robin die
over the years Batman's made it really
clear that he is not afraid to break
every single bone in his body to catch
criminals but if you really want to hurt
him you kill his sidekick later in the
1960s like a couple years after that
they debuted like the new look era where
Bob Kane didn't have like draconian rule
over the look and feel of Batman Carmine
Infantino came in and took the character
down an even darker route this is where
we're trying to get into like really
dark crime drama but not quite as dark
as Frank Miller 80s era some really good
books from that era to read are fright
of the Scarecrow from Batman number 189
The Outsider saga which is Detective
Comics 328 all the way through 356 and
if you want a really good poison ivy
story there's beware of poison ivy giant
exclamation point that's Batman number
181 then we move into the 1970s in the
arrival of Rachel ghoul crazy psychopath
Joker comes back you get less
lighthearted Robin and you get more of
like the dark justice if you ever
watched the flash this year the
reverse-flash
really railed on Batman as this version
of you know dark
justice that he felt was really bad it
says a lot when the reverse-flash thinks
that you're too dark but that's
basically what Batman was during this
Neil Adams era dark Avenger of the night
the funny thing is is that every 10
years you know like new artists come
along and say you know I'm gonna make
Batman way darker than he's ever been
before you know until you get to Frank
Miller I don't think anybody can go
darker than Frank Miller a really good
Joker story from from this era is called
Joker's five-way revenge that's Batman
number 251 there's night of the stalker
that's Batman number 439 and then of
course there's the first big ratio goal
arc starting with Batman number 232 so
moving into the 1980s this decade
obviously dominated by Frank Miller both
in the Dark Knight Returns and in Batman
year one two very different stories with
very different artwork but both some of
the best Batman stories of all time in
fact Dark Knight Returns was such a
popular story that it spawned a sequel
Dark Knight Returns part two and now
just now in the last year they've
commissioned Frank Miller to do Dark
Knight Returns part three like literally
you know 2015-2016 dartnet returns of
the story is intended to bookend
everything that came before crisis on
Infinite Earths year one came after
Infinite Crisis and was like a rebooting
of the origin story there's so many
other great Batman stories from this era
you have Killing Joke he have Arkham
Asylum serious house on Sirius earth a
death in the family obviously you know
big Robin's story so Frank Miller might
be the most popular 80s Batman writer
but there are a lot of other great
Batman stories moving into the 1990s was
like my personal beginning with Batman
especially around the nightfall era what
happened during this period is is that
you know building on the success of the
the Tim Burton Batman films and
obviously you know Frank Miller's big
hits in the 1980s DC wanted to do like a
big you know never gonna see it again
type event they wanted to break the
Batman you also have to remember this is
the same era that they killed off
Superman in it's like hey let's do
something really huge some big event
that's never gonna happen again which of
course ended up not being true because
you get batman r.i.p get a whole bunch
of different stories so even though
batman can never die he gets killed an
awful lot so starting in like Batman
number 491 in Detective Comics number
659 they started to spin out the Bane
character like that was his debut in the
comics
he was supposed to be like a really dark
spin on the Doc Savage character who was
going to try and break the Batman in
body and soul like the best anti Batman
you could think of just like doomsday
became the ultimate ante Superman so
moving into the 2000s we're entering
like Gimli Batman era one of the most
famous Batman artists of all time and
one of the most successful ones he's
been successful for a number of reasons
in addition to being a great artist you
know he obviously created the Wildstorm
universe but even though I'm not a big
fan of Grant Morrison's r.i.p Batman's
storyline he did bring us Damian Wayne
he's the one that created the Damian
Wayne character probably like the most
popular version of Robin in the last 10
years I will say you know before he
debuted I completely lost interest in
that character there are a lot of
different versions of Robin you know
anyone wearing this suit you know just
didn't register with me when I was a
little kid Damian Wayne came along and
suddenly it was a lot more fun just like
an little kid and Batman had to
deal with him after Jim Lee did that
hush storyline with Jeff lobe though he
went on to do all-star Batman with Frank
Miller so you have like one of the best
writers with one of the best artists I
will say that like the new version of
Batman like this Gordon mech wearing
suit is gonna be a little bit weird but
I mean we'll see how it goes I'm always
open to new things so here's my big
question for you guys you know what's
your favorite versions of Batman
character either in the video games or
in the comic books I know I mentioned
the square-enix Comic Con exclusive
Batman figure like the really creepy
looking mech Batman but Gimli also
designed another Comic Con exclusive
Batman very you know very different look
it just depends on you know which
version the character you prefer you
know and how fast you elbow your way
into line
seriously you have not lived until you
try to get a comic-con exclusive toy
those are some of the first things to go
like on preview night on Wednesdays
we're still a little ways out from
comic-con I'll have some special content
for that you know we mostly like film
movies and TV but I will try to do a
couple cool giveaways just like I did
last year so there might be like some
fun toys to be had I know it's been a
little while since I've done a Gotham
video so I'll try to do a bonus video
for that because there's a couple
characters that they have announced in a
couple people like two-face for instance
that have been bumped up to cast regular
so we're gonna see two-face all of next
season that's actually a good idea for
my next Gotham bonus video I'll do a
two-face video so be sure to subscribe
to get that I'll try to post that next
week if you guys do have any other
requests just leave them in the comments
below
I might be persuaded to give away a copy
or two of Arkham Knight whenever that
comes out in a couple weeks but tomorrow
I should be posting flash and arrow
videos I think you know flash mirror
master at least so look out for that in
the meantime you guys can click here for
my latest Suicide Squad video ant you
can click here for my flash season 2
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow